I really wish I could just be blindly
excited for everything okay so I'm going
to talk about the defenders and
specifically why I'm kind of nervous for
it because this was something that set
on gradually for me and I couldn't
figure out initially why I was feeling
this way and I've analyzed I think I've
got to figure it out now so a quick
recap the defenders is basically to the
Marvel Netflix shows what the Avengers
was to the Marvel theatrically released
movies it is the team-up show it is
going to feature daredevil Jessica Jones
Luke Cage and iron fist all together
taking on we don't know exactly what but
it's their big team-up event and it's
something that I have been looking
forward to I mean why wouldn't I I like
more all the vast majority of Marvel's
output immensely now I'm nervous about
it and the initial blame for that is
going to land at the feet of iron fist
and not just for the obvious reason now
to recap iron fist the show was not good
iron fist Danny Rand the character was
really not good I really could not stand
this character I don't think I was alone
in that assessment so that gives the
initial obvious concern which is that
I'm stuck with this guy that isn't
really where my fear is coming from
because I mean he's going to get bounced
down by other characters and all this
stuff so I had to think why is this
actually making me nervous because
before I even came out but the initial
critical word without it wasn't good I
sort of posited the question you know
what if it sucks what does that mean I
said at the time and I don't think it's
going to matter much because Marvel as
the entity as an entertainment producing
machine is just going to keep grinding
for it it'll and this isn't going to
slow the momentum I'm not entirely sure
that's true now and this isn't because
like Iron Fist is so bad and go to the
track a look at that no it's something
like that it has to do with the fact
that the Marvel Cinematic Universe even
though we refer to it as this one big
thing it's not
really it may have intended to be at one
point and I know technically everything
is happening within the same continuity
but in reality we are dealing with three
different universes for all intents and
purposes we have the film's we have
Netflix and we have ages of shields
which will also soon incorporate the
Inhumans as well I don't know where
cloak and dagger fits on all this that
might be something else now the reason
I'm dividing these up is because again
even though technically they haven't in
the same universes and we've had some
Easter eggs and some confirmations of
that connection
they're not gonna cross over and then a
huge meaningful way and they kind of
never did the only time one massively
impacted the other was the events of
Winter Soldier impacting agents of
shield that was really the only time it
happened it hasn't happened since the
reason for that is because Kevin Feige
who runs the movies and I Perlmutter who
runs the television division they a
fight he used to answer to Perlmutter
the two do not get along at all and
fight you went over his head to Disney
saying I can't keep answering to this
guy and they basically split the two
apart and now they work separately
they're not going to start working
together on this stuff now theoretically
that kind of logistical doesn't exist
between say ages of children the Netflix
shows but those aren't going to
crossover for a much more basic reason
they are aiming for a completely
different sort of demographic and type
of entertainment I mean the use of
shields is on ABC it is aiming for a
family audience Netflix and not so much
it's much harsher and when you mix what
is effectively a pg-13 property with an
art property you're going to either make
the art property looks off or you're
going to be bringing people over from
the pg-13 who aren't ready for the art
stuff though that stuff's not going to
crossover either so once we look at the
fact that the we called the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but we've got the
movies we've got Netflix we've got
standard TV and we look at just Netflix
because that's what Iron Fist is going
to impact and we realize the Netflix
isn't quite at the same point so if
Marvel produces a flat-out bad
movie which again I've said this before
I don't think they have as yet I think
the worst of the movies have been is
disposable and some of their films have
been but I've never regretted watching
any of their films but even if something
comes out it's safe for instance I don't
know black panther is awful and painful
the movies have so much momentum in so
much history behind them in and you know
proof of concept do someone so that's
just going to plow right through that's
not where the Netflix shows are right
now so iron fist sucking which again it
does a lot is not the same as I get me
on something like black panther or
spider-man homecoming or even the next
Avengers movie sucking it's more like
what if Captain America the First
Avenger had sucked
what if people didn't like it what if
people didn't like Chris Evan the Steve
Rogers we would have been in potentially
really big trouble going into the
Avengers because he is a part of that
and they were already in production for
that when the Captain America film came
out and we were in the same boat with
the defenders already be in production
when iron fist came out so the situation
we've got with Netflix isn't really
analogous to anything that could happen
with the movies because the room we'd
already blown past that that point the
sort of point in its own evolution that
the Netflix shows are in right now but
that's not the only problem the other
problem is what's the threat gonna be
what's the story going to be because
right now the obvious indication and if
you remember the the teaser you know
what sort of an image is peeling away
what was left with with the word
defenders on it it was a hand the hand
is not good villain material and if
that's going to be the main thrust of
what the defenders are facing that's not
a good sign and if that's it and it's
not just because you know they're
lacking a figurehead though that's part
of a problem I'll touch back on that
again in a minute but the thing problem
is the hand is there far too nebulous
it's not clear exactly what their
mission statement is what
they are after you know even the exact
housing wise of how they operate are
still just too vague it makes some kind
of unthreatening we don't know enough
about them to be properly threatened
particularly since we've seen them get
their butts handed to them repeatedly
you compare that to say hydra hydra has
worked as villain first of all right off
the bat they spun off from the Nazis oh
well we all grab that right away but
it's also had appropriate figure heads
it had red skull and then when it got
over on to agents of shield it had Bill
Paxton character whose name I forget it
had that scientist who didn't appear to
be aging it had Ward I mean Ward is so
much more interesting as a villain than
anything that has ever come out of the
hand now we may be getting reprieve with
that because a Sigourney Weaver is going
to be playing the villain exactly who
she is who she's commanding how she fits
into things we don't know yet but
scorning Lieber is a great presence and
a great get and hopefully whoever the
melon is there she's going to be able to
pull it together but I don't know if
that's going to be enough because I look
at all the threads that are left to be
picked up picked up by the other show
then it's the hand it's the sort of
hints to jessica jones origins it may be
some of the stuff with the
experimentation that created Luke Cage
initially it's frankly the least
interesting stuff of each of these
series and to try and take all the worst
bits and try and build the team up
around that you know what it's not even
like what you'll be having iron fists
suck and the pieces that they appear to
be making the defenders out of just
saying that iron fist sucks would have
been like if the captain mark of the
first Avengers up no no because also
since the hand suck so bad
imagine if we were going into the first
Avengers movie and Captain America the
First Avenger head sucked and Loki
sucked that's where we are right now in
terms of the pieces that they're being
assembled now does that mean that it
can't be good no of course not it could
still be good it could still be great
but they're building this thing out of
faulty parts and that makes me nervous
and if it was just Danny Rand I probably
wouldn't be as nervous knowing the hand
that's another thing and also you know I
kind of implied the Danny ramp might get
canceled out by the other three I'm not
sure that's going to be true either
because they're all kind of similar in
terms of where they are as a persona as
a person and I don't need these are not
identical characters I'm not saying that
but I mean they're all ghoul angsty kind
of you know in the dumps characters as
did Gerald personality the lightest guys
probably Luke Cage and he's an
ex-convict with a dead wife so he can be
kind of morose sometimes so when you've
got all of these first when they've all
got downer personalities I don't know
how that's going to balance as a team I
mean to contrast with the movies and
with the Avengers yeah you've got some
folks who were a little more down in the
dumps you know you've got Bruce Banner
was a little bit man but then you've got
you know Captain America very stalwart
and Noble and then you've got iron man
who is just having fun with all that you
know you have distinctly different
personalities you see how they play off
each other I look at the characters in
the Barry's Netflix shows and even
though I have enjoyed three out of four
of the Netflix shows I think about the
basic operating premise of the
personality of these characters and
they're all a little too similar like
between the guy who is bummed out
because out on Catholic guilt the woman
who is still getting over severe trauma
the guy who was wrongly convicted and
found out that his new girlfriend killed
his old wife and the entitled douchebag
who is a comic relief in a suit who's
you know the one who's going to be happy
who's got yeah and I'm not saying that
young we must have memory I'm just
saying like fever these are all sort of
characters and you know in their own
shows it works because they have their
own supporting cast to buoy them a bit
more you know daredevil has foggy and
that held
a great deal Luke Cage had a number of
characters he had that all the guy in
the barbershop whose name suddenly
escaping me I loved him Jessica Jones
had her friend and Danny Randle Danny
read didn't have anybody but again
that's so suck well you know if they're
already come and they might even bring
some of their supporting cast along for
the ride but they're going to be even
more background than they are and the
normal shows so I don't see how this is
going to balance and again you know it
could still work and I would like it to
work and I'm certainly going to watch it
but the more I think about the pieces
and the components that are being put
together to make this new show the more
it makes me kind of go
please don't slack because I'm now
seeing what happens when a Marvel Marvel
Netflix show sucks and I don't want to
slog through another season of crap
desire fist I not again know so that is
why I'm currently concerned I'm still
going to see it
I mean Marvel has built up more than
enough you know good will with me there
it's gonna be a while they're going to
need a long string of really bad
decisions before I hit you know the
point I'm at with DC where they you know
I'm not given the money my money anymore
so I'm nowhere near that but I'm nervous
and I haven't been nervous for a Marvel
property in a in ever like ever I don't
think I've ever been this nervous about
a Marvel property even knowing the
reviews going into Iron Fist I wasn't
this nervous so yeah that's where I am
on this what are your thoughts about the
defenders what are your hopes for what
are your concerns about it whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it don't forget to
Like subscribe check me out on Twitter
council of geek give a listen to the
council of east podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and also check out
my other podcast punch like a girl it's
on a separate podcast feed thank you so
much for tuning in and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]